que ces porte soit fermée ou ouverte au
gré des confinement valérie bosser reste
positive sa librairie le fureteur a
connu en 2020 une de ses meilleures
années
que ce soit pour les ventes en magasin
commande en ligne ou par téléphone de sa
femme explosive
disons qu'en temps normal peut-être
qu'on faisait cinq disques dit postaux
par jour le c'était 80 90 colis postaux
marché en magasin il aurait fait deux
d'excellentes journée des mois qui bon
avant noël à l'automne parfois c'est
presque 50% de plus qu'en qu'à pareille
date l'année dernière
même constat dans les librairies
montréalaise du square les ventes ont
progressé de plus de 50% depuis juillet
cette tendance se vérifie dans les
librairies indépendantes du québec en
2020 les ventes au grand public ont
augmenté de 10 8% et 2 5% pour tous les
publics
donc en incluant les écoles et les
bibliothèques et la raison de ce succès
est assez simple pour les libraires les
[ __ ] et atx et cinéma et pas de
spectacles les restaurants on peut pas
sortir non plus rough culturel les gens
n'ont trouvé dans les livres ils ont
redécouvert le plaisir de la lecture
donc on leur ramener une cliente est
qu'ils aient pu ça je suis
particulièrement content parce que moi
c'est là la clientèle que j'ai toujours
désiré ramener au bercail ceux qui
avaient un peu désertes et des hôtels
navire et la pandémie à cet effet l'on
le livre est donc devenu le premier
produit de consommation culturelle un
refuge pour bien des gens et c'est vers
leur librairie de quartier qu'ils se
sont tournés en priorité la littérature
d'ici a aussi profité de cet engouement
les ventes des éditeurs québécois ont
augmenté de près de 7% dans les
librairies indépendantes en 2020
les libraires espère maintenant que cet
appétit pour la lecture va se maintenir
une fois tourné la lourde page de cette
crise sanitaire
j'ose espérer que l'engouement va rester
je croirais aussi c'est un plaisir de
vraiment les gens redécouvrent le
plaisir découvre des auteurs
crois bien que le lait votre gagnant
tant et aussi longtemps que les gens
prennent pas leurs activités normales
parce que confiné ou pas confiné rien ne
vaut un bon bouquin entre les mains ici
catherine françois radio canada montréal